I spent a year courting him to do an
interview he finally agreed to do an
interview actually at the start of this
year I was 2 days away from getting on a
plane from Los Angeles to Austin in
Texas to do it with him and at the last
minute he suddenly sent me because he
was doing all the organization himself
on direct message on X he suddenly sent
me a clip that someone have posted that
day from an interview I did with zubie
at the start of December in which I
criticized Elon for bringing Alex Jones
back to x uh something he'd always said
he wouldn't do and he said that he'd
lost all respect for me because I had
said that and the interview was
summarily cancelled uh so I never got
the chance to interview him which is a
great regret because I think he's
probably the most fascinating guy in the
world right now